step aside made the picture about women in
sports they may not run as fast as us men nor
jump as high but every girl is an attraction
in action a perfect picture of grace that's
grace nearest the camera the girls with get up
and go take their sport seriously and it's not
drawing the Longboat a state that they can show
us fellas a thing or two including a pretty leg
no girl can resist putting her oar
in so no wonder crew is popular at
college imagine getting so many girls
together in one spot all doing the same
thing and what's more all wearing
the same costume heavens to Betsy
when it's time for tea you'll find golfing's
greatest gals driving him almost
as far as the hardest hit him in
but it's putting where the pretties really copped
the cups the fair sex on fairway or on the green
dropped those plots like threading a needle we
all lose sportsmanship is served when the girls
get together anyone for tennis some of the most
publicized female athletes are in this racket
tennis it may not be love love at first serve
but she sure gives it a try nowhere in the world
of women play the game like our all-american
champs of yesterday and today Helen Jacobs
Alice Marvell Helen Wills Maureen Connelly
queens of the court our credit to the game
some of the biggest wheels and womanly sport
are found traveling in the best of circles
in Germany that's where these king-sized
hopes were invented Rome wheels so-called
after the wrong mountains near Hertzberg
flying far line sure gets round in one of
these vertical Mary grounds and whether
she's up or down she's having a wheel of
a time the American version Kakao gal out
of the saddle now let's see what happens
twork on the lone prairie so get along little
Gary a roll into the rollers will cool you are
the girls will do anything the fellas will do
that goes for football and these bruising bills
go for the game in a big way the dead layer of
the species take time off before the kickoff to
be sure every little curl is in place but that
doesn't mean they use powder puffs for pig skins
no man this is for real real rough and tough pick
them up slam them down football go girl go go
football is a tough subject and a passing
grade doesn't always mean the victory not
when the mean old opposition intercepts
and runs like crazy for a touchdown
now what are the girls up to roller basketball
all laced up to Lacey to the pole and let the
hips fall where they may here are some fancy
footwork by lasses who know a thing or two about
passes to the task of the basket
ease of basket and when blonde
meets brunette his lamb Olivia you
suppose they're fighting over the man
rougher than roller basketball shucks rubber than
bargaining in the basement is the roller derby a
sport for those who seek self-expression water
expression early the birds background for the
let's face it anything the men can
do the girls can do better and maybe
rougher take wrestling for instance
lady Grassley as it's popularly known
we're gals with dramatic
talent coming to their home
all acted out according to the script not as
well as it looks but all in all quite a show
there's no getting around it girls
are pretty and they do pretty things
especially in a lovely ensemble of much
beauty which makes for a water ballet
underwater they're just as
appealing graceful antics of
long legs light lovely lassies that's
it up close so we can get a good look
there's nothing prettier to watch
than a pretty diver fair informed
ease of execution a sight mr.
the pumps and quicken the eye
what's this honey's hair flies she whirls through
the two-and-a-half off the high platform but all
the color it's still a competitive sport
and competition reaches its zenith in the
Olympic Games fires burning and flanks flying
the best qualified and most physically fit of
All Nations compete for world championships
they have got to be good to throw the discus
but then they should maybe girls get that
way tossing dishes around the kitchen here a
girl gets a chance to throw things while
the men just stand around and measured
who says there are no flying saucers shot
pudding is an unusual sport for girls and
it takes an unusual girl to do it
scram Mac this is woman's picture
then her husband's on time for dinner
whatever the event the girls seek to
jump a little higher or run a little faster
raising the bar or beating the clock the record
book of the Olympic Games lists many a fair
contender who broke records and thrilled fans
from the four corners of the earth they came to
write their names on the pages of sporting history
watch that second girl
as exciting a finish as any
male athlete ever turned in
when again sets her sights on victory
world of sports is a keener livelier place
okay man you can get in the picture now and
what a picture when bathing beauties come
out to pose why they just naturally have to be
seen and photographed hey bub take off your hat
chiefly Queens on water skis provide speed
trails excitement at action what happened to her
waterskiing began in France as a novelty and it's
grown in popular every passing year now it's a
recognized competitive sport due in great measure
to the enthusiastic acceptance of the girls
but whatever the sport wherever you find our
comely champs old records go
and new heights are reached
so here's a toast to flashing finger